déjà épinglé par le passé pour ses
supposés liens avec des jld
une mise en examen pour financement du
terrorisme et mise en danger de la vie
d'ancien salariés d'une usine en syrie
lafarge se retrouve à nouveau au coeur
d'un scandale
et cette fois ci ça se passe ici même à
paris dans le quartier de bercy
dans cette vidéo on voit un camion de
cimentiers déverser ses eaux usées dans
un bassin de décantation et via un trou
dans la cuve l'eau s'écoule directement
dans la seine dont le rejeter des
particules de ciment mais aussi des
tiges plastiques utilisés pour rendre le
béton plus résistant des déchets qui
étouffe les poissons et polluent la
fleur de la scène des images tournées le
27 août dernier par jacques lemoine un
garde-pêche pour qui cet incident est
loin d'être accidentel
clairement ces volontaires dans ses
cuves se sont toutes les eaux les restes
de béton fabriqués dans la journée qui
reviennent dans les camions en fin de
journée ensuite la société et son sait
traiter ces déchets seulement sur ce
site
elle ne le fait pas et elle se permet de
le rejeter dans la scène volontairement
et selon les gardes-pêche lusine
déverserait ses eaux usées depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
pour preuve la couche de ciment sécher
visible sur les quais lafarge se targue
pourtant de prêter une grande attention
à l'environnement
nous avons tenté à plusieurs reprises de
joindre le cimentier
sans succès lafarge s'est contenté de
nous envoyer un communiqué dans lequel
le groupe se dit victime d'un acte de
vandalisme en avril 2019
l'élu de la france insoumise danielle
simonnet alertait déjà sur la présence
d'une centrale à béton du groupe lafarge
en zone inondable dans le 15e
arrondissement
elle demandait à la ville de paris
d'annuler le permis de construire
accordés aux cimentiers les riverains
nous alertaient sur le fait que lafarge
n'hésitez pas à rejeter dans la seine
les eaux usées quand il nettoyait les
camions toupies quoi et qui avait aussi
un problème sur le bac le réservoir des
eaux usées qui pouvaient déborder s'est
coulé dans la seine la ville c'était
quand même engagé à réétudier le permis
de construire est asocial asocial et
rivera mais en fait il pas ont été très
peu associés
la ville ayant déjà accordés par mes
confrères je trouve n'a pas mené la
bataille mais surtout sur les questions
environnementales liées à la scène la
ville n'avait absolument pas bouger rien
n'avait été fait aucune réponse à
l'époque de la mairie de paris
depuis les choses ont peut-être un peu
changé la mairie socialiste qui doit sa
victoire aux dernières municipales à une
alliance avec les écologistes s'est
montré plus réactive
c'est un véritable scandale écologique
alors que nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires depuis de nombreuses années
pour améliorer la qualité du fleuve
la ville de paris va saisir le procureur
de la république pour ces faits graves
qui portent atteinte à notre
environnement
accident ou acte délibéré par souci
d'économie une chose est sûre avec ce
nouveau caillou dans les chaussures le
cimentier va devoir bétonner sa défense